foreign
in Atlanta what's up Steven
hey Dr John how are you today I'm good
brother what's up man
all right so I'll just start with saying
um this year has been a long year for me
uh just I've had a long time with just
burnout I would I guess I would say
uh dealing with my job have another baby
on the way and um you know I just feel
exhausted yeah
well um how can I help man
I guess uh you know I've
had three panic attacks in the past
several months and yeah and lead with
that next time dude
sorry about that yeah I got a busy job
and a baby and I'm dying hey
and uh yeah so yeah I definitely had
some experience where I felt like that I
was gonna die a couple times
um yeah and different times I just felt
lightheaded and uh
really don't know where to go from there
cool
so we're going to start at the top and
I'm going to peel this thing apart okay
is that cool
sure
um tell me to stop asking questions if
you ever say like I'm just don't answer
anymore
um and know this this exploration will
help a lot of people okay it's pretty
it's a brave call you made
um so a panic attack is your body
getting it's really overriding the
system okay it's it's telling you hey
you clearly aren't hearing me
so uh I'm sounding every alarm I have
all of them same time
okay it's a just an over regulation it's
a dysregulation of the regulatory system
right
so let's back out
um tell me about your job what do you do
for a living
uh I work in the automotive industry
okay service advisor as a what advisor
service advisor okay what about that job
is burning you out
um really handling about 20 to 30
customers a day okay
and working about 12 hours a day okay
why do you do that job man
uh the money's good how much is good
what kind of money do you make
uh I would say upwards of 150 000 okay
150 Grand a year okay great salary
as far as helping customers I loved
dealing with that aspect
it's just the hours are daunting you
just told me that the worst part of the
job was 30 or 40 customers a day or 20
30 customers a day and it's the best
part
um helping the customers is the best
part uh but yeah I guess you're right
about that
um 20 to 30 customers can be
overwhelming okay for me
um tell me about these hours why do you
work these crazy hours is that just what
the job demands
that's what the job demands right
do you have any other kids wife married
anything like that
uh wife and I have a two-year-old son
okay tell me about your home life tell
me about your wife
oh my wife is wonderful
um our marriage uh couldn't ask for more
she's a wonderful support
um my son I love him to death I try to
go home and spend time as much as
possible with him okay
for him or with him
uh with him okay
so have you created a life for yourself
this is a side question
um
what do you owe
as far as from a financial standpoint
yep
um I'm debt-free except for my house
okay so what do you own your mortgage
uh
uh 165 000 left on my mortgage
to quit your job right now quit it
yeah
okay what I just did after that
what I just would I sometimes I'll just
say hey just break up with her
just quit your job
and I want to know what people's gut is
and your response I'm judging you by one
syllable but you're like yeah
what is it like you make a great salary
but financially speaking you're better
off than 99.9 of people in the in in on
planet Earth
all right
yo 165 Grand you're gonna have no house
payment how old are you 34.
how old
34. okay 34. so by 36 you'll be you'll
have no house payment
you don't owe anybody anything
and for 150 Grand you're choosing to
live a life of misery and disruption why
is that
I guess because I've been doing it for
almost 10 years and I
really haven't really sought out
anything else
when the story on you is written
like on the Epitaph would you love it to
say helped a lot of people with their
Automotive issues no that's not a bad
thing I mean that's like man I fixed a
lot of cars I help people get to work
and get to the hospital that's not a bad
thing I'm just asking is that what you
want on on
etched into stone next to your name
no I mean absolutely not what do you
want to do
um
I guess really just that I was an
individual that laid down
my life or others and laid down my heart
for others to help others
um get the point a from point A to point
B okay and so do you see that your work
is in service to that mission
because I do I get it
right
I mean I I can see that you know as far
as
helping people with their cars and
everything but I I don't know I'm just I
guess I'm looking for more in life than
just that yeah there you go
um tell me about your buddies who do you
hang out with once a week just to grab a
beer with the nachos with who's your
gang
really I have no one um
because I've wrapped my life and family
and work okay
um
I don't know if you can do this but tell
me about the crummiest boss you have
uh well I mean currently I actually do
not have any crummy bosses everybody's
good how many bosses in the past
everybody's good I mean I have a great
relationship with all my bosses okay
foreign
so if I were to ask you man what's your
body trying to get your attention like
what's it trying to tell you what would
your answer to that be
rest
tell me more
um just going going and not giving time
for myself
okay
is that going going going your body's
version of laying down its life for
everybody else
I would say so
okay some reason we got in our heads
that if it doesn't hurt it's not a good
workout and if it doesn't hurt then it's
not a good if we're not hurting then
we're not sacrificing and crushing
ourselves on behalf of our wives or our
kids then we're not putting it all in or
if we're dying at the altar of our job
or our paycheck that somehow we're if
we're not dying at the altar of our
paycheck we're somehow screwed something
up and I think that's stupid
my friend Sal over at the Mind pump guys
was the first guy I'd ever heard say
that a lot of people work out until
they're sore
because they hate their bodies
and there's some sort of underlying idea
that I need to punish myself through
this workout
to to to to make sure my body gets to
message that the way it looks is
unacceptable and he he's like dude
that's a recipe for Burnout
and so some some story that you're
operating under says that
you have to do all of these things
and your body's trying to get your
attention say hey hey we can't do all
these things we cannot work 12 hours a
day six days a week we cannot be fully
present with our kids we cannot have the
greatest marriage ever we cannot
um we're out I'm out
is that fair oh and then you throw
another kid on there and then your
body's like oh good thanks thanks Steven
that's what we need that's what we
needed another human
yeah no I I totally agree with what
you're saying who told you that uh 12
hours a day six days a week was was the
way the way to fulfill your duty
uh no one really told me that somebody
modeled up somebody modeled that for you
um I guess I just kind of become
accustomed to it um well I mean
as far as when I first started my job
that was the norm of everybody that's in
this industry
um work work work and
no rest and then um you know
once rest kind of comes and you pick up
and work again have you seen some of the
dudes that are 45 and 55 in your
industry
I have they look a hundred
they do
their bodies are a hundred
is that the life you want for yourself
not really no okay
Okay so
here's what I'm trying to give you
choice
often I talk to folks in your situation
and they owe a hundred thousand dollars
in student loans and they have two car
payments and they owe five hundred
thousand dollars on their mortgage and
so this conversation is very different
because I tell them you're gonna have
two or three years more of this
um so that you can dig out of the hole
that you dug for yourself
and then you can fill in the blank you
don't have that issue
you have a wide array of choices
all burnout is is when your body says
hey you have been listening to us so
clearly you're not you don't know what
you're doing we're taking over
it's like when you're in driver's ed and
there's a another break
on the on the instructor's side of the
car too
so that he can slam on that break if you
are missing it as a driving student
that's what you're that's what a panic
attack is it's your body just shutting
the thing down because you clearly
aren't getting the message and so what I
would love you to do is to start to get
the message
it starts with here's like you're create
you're talking about an anxious life
right that's what you're talking about
you have a life that's just buzzing all
the time is that correct right that's
correct how much coffee do you drink
uh one cup in the morning really
yeah good for you man
gosh I think I had seven this morning
that's impressive how do you go to sleep
at night
I do yeah
so there's something else you're not
telling me
um
I mean as far as how's your how's your I
know your wife's pregnant you have a
two-year-old how's your sex life how's
your intimacy life
there it is right there there it is do
what
maybe once every three weeks right now I
mean of course it was about once a week
but
um just the way you said well
um
so whenever somebody says hey I have an
anxious life here's the life before me
okay
the three buckets I like to to look at
before anything else
is number one uh there's four buckets
actually number one is physiological
I'd recommend at this point if you've
had three panic attacks go see your
doctor okay
get your heart checked get your thyroid
checked get your testosterone checked
get some of these basic low-level things
check just to make sure okay all right
the second thing is
if you if you open your eyes you know
six thousand years ago and you were on
the planes of Texas and your tribe had
left you you were probably going to die
wired into us at our more most core
function
is this idea that we have to be around
other people and I tell new dads and new
moms all the time the greatest gift you
can give your toddler
is to go have your own friends
to leave the house once a week and go
hang out with your friends
I took my 12 year old son I have a
we are incredible Stephen I got like a
rock and roll band that I'm jamming with
okay I brought my 12 year old over the
other day he watched us for about 12
minutes until he's about to fall asleep
on the couch and then I said you can go
outside and swim in this guy's pool
by the way get a guy in your band that
has a pool it's way it's super great
um but I wanted him to see his dad
having friends
and I wanted him to see my life does not
revolve around him
because he is not strong enough to be
the center of my solar system
and he'll try to be
okay
so getting with your wife and saying Hey
I want you to start having
friends that you do life with
and so once a week so you hear me say
y'all are planning to be a part two
nights out of a week minimum
I want her to go start spending the
evening with some girlfriends and that
means you're gonna do dinner you're
gonna do bath time you're gonna do
bedtime
okay you're gonna get plugged in in that
way and you're gonna put your phone down
and you're just gonna be there as
annoying as that is
ah it's gonna be the worst and but I'm
still gonna plug in that way
and
you're gonna get a couple of dudes
you're gonna start hanging out and
that's gonna be weird and awkward 35 is
the single it's the worst time to start
making friends and here you are okay
your brain will not rest until you've
got a gang
all right and I would also recommend
they not be work people either
gotcha okay
the the third bucket is this idea of
safety
are you in a place that's not safe and
you told me no I don't have a toxic work
environment my marriage is fantastic
um Family Life Is Good your debt to Inc
I mean you've got basically no debt man
you're almost paid your whole house off
you're not even 40 years old yet which
is just astounding it's incredible then
the third thing is autonomy and this is
the big another big one where your body
isn't in control of what happens
tomorrow
and it can often look up after being at
the same job for 10 years and you're
working 12 hours a day six days a week
and it begins to feel like this is the
rest of my life
and that's what your body begins to
revolt because it doesn't have a say in
what happens tomorrow
and so you have to start having the
conversation with yourself about what
does my work life look like in the next
two to three years
like do I need to go get credentials do
I need to go to college do I need to get
something like what do I actually want
to do
in service to this greater Mission and
by the way like follow your passion I
think that's just stupid I'm just not a
passion guy
um we're passionate about the things
that we're good at and we're good at the
things that we practice and we practice
the things usually that we have to right
so
um I liked guitar I thought guys who
were playing guitar looked cool and they
seem to have dates a lot so then I
started playing it and I hated it
because it was hard and then I liked
being able to play one song and then 35
years later I'm passionate about guitars
you see what I'm saying it wasn't like
I'm passionate about this thing I have
this feeling about man
it doesn't it doesn't usually work in
reverse and so I care less about what
you're passionate about and more about
dude who are you what do you want to do
and then do you have any sort of
exercise practice at all
I'm trying to implement that into my
life right now no as Yoda says there's
no try just do it man
just do it just do it get a couple of
dumbbells from Academy and just take
them to your house and start there
you can get through the next six months
of your life with two dumbbells and
that's about it
Yeah okay or get on Craigslist and buy
just some Shenanigans I have a dope home
gym that is made up almost entirely of
Craigslist finds oh nice okay and it
took me like three or four or five years
to accumulate it all just keep doing it
it's fantastic man
but you have to build that in and I'm
not talking about a two and a half hour
Beefcake McGee workout go outside and do
30 minutes and lift some weights go
outside and go for a jog go outside and
walk around in nature okay
the last thing I'll tell you is this
um if you can incorporate all this
together
get your dumbbells and go outside in
your backyard and do your morning
workout in the Sun
even when it's cold
get some sunlight and get some nature
and get some exercise and get some
movement and get some coffee you see
what I'm saying we're talking about
slowly tweaking the edges of our life
it's gonna have a ripple effect all the
way through the middle of it
all right got it
now I just told you a bunch of stuff
does that say like okay I'm in for that
or like man you're an idiot no I'm
actually absolutely into that okay I'd
love to keep up with you as you're
walking
um if you're like me I don't like
calling doctors I've been to my primary
care physician zero times in the last
five years so much so that I went and
got like special doctors because I just
don't want to go to a record doctor
please call and make a appointment with
with the primary care doctor
okay
have you done that yet
I actually have how'd that go
um everything checked out fine okay cool
the physical Spectrum good bucket bucket
done now before I let you go
one of the the like no no one uh let's
see lesson number one in counseling
class whenever I was teaching grad
school or I was in grad school
lesson number one your clients will lie
to you
they'll tell you most of the story are
part of a story so before I let you go
to put you on the spot completely
something in my guts tells me there's
something else
am I wrong
not that I can think of I mean I plan on
being straightforward with you
throughout this whole thing so I mean I
I don't have anything that I can think
about that like you're not cheating on
your wife you don't have like an
addiction or owe somebody a bunch of
money or something
I do not no sir
Stephen yes you know I'm just messing
with you no that's fantastic that's
awesome dude here's the thing you sound
like an incredible guy
you sound like an incredible guy
and there's people this is hard for us
to wrap our heads around
um
I think his name was Marlon Ramsey was
the the
race when I was I was a track athlete in
high school and kind of a wannabe poser
in college
and I remember
buying into coaches saying like man you
can do anything you can be so fast you
can do all these things you just got to
work hard to work hard and work hard
and so I thought my Excellence was a
function of my hard work which in many
ways it was but it was my excellence and
I think his name was Marlon Ramsey I
think he went on to run it Baylor and
then in the Olympics but I got
he ended up on in the same heat of a
race as me at the rice Invitational
relays there in Texas in Houston
and he beat me so bad
like he just annihilated me and I
remember realizing that I think I was a
freshman maybe a sophomore and I
remember realizing
I could never exercise and work hard and
be that fast that dude's just faster
than me and he's working as hard as me
so there's a gap right so that same
thing with jumping like Michael Jordan
or doing squats like Lane Norton like I
could do squats every day and follow a
great program I'm not going to set the
world record I'm just not
here's what I'm telling you that
we look around in the Instagram world
that we live in in the yeah crush it
kill it world
and there's some people
that are just Ford f-350s
they seem to be able to do 12-hour days
six days a week and go and go and go and
go
and we don't have any long-term data
when the that engine craps out right but
it just they we see them and we see
their success
and for many of us we have to look in
the mirror and say
I'm a I'm a Camry
it's a great car and it's gonna last
forever
but I can't do a job that is six 12-hour
days for 50 years and call it
I'm put here to do something different
my job is not to pull a building down my
job is not to carry heavy equipment my
job is to get people from A to B I'm
going to be the best A to B getter
person in the world
you see what I'm saying
right I do you may have put yourself in
a situation where this isn't the job for
me
or this isn't the life I want to live in
this particular season
and I've told us on the show before but
there came a moment when I was about
your age almost identical to your age
actually
when my wife and I took a 70 000
household income pay cut
and I quit working at a giant at not a
giant but at a large University running
a big ship and I went to a
bigger University but working with a
smaller subset of students
um The Prestige was still enough so that
my ego could prop itself up but the pay
was less the responsibility was less and
then I spent a season working out I got
an engine replacement
and then I got an engine replacement I
got new wheels and new brakes and new
tires and I learned new things and I got
new skills and I got a little bit wiser
A Little Bit Stronger then all of a
sudden I was a way different vehicle
does that make sense
it does so just a season it was good I'm
glad I had it during the middle of it I
hated every second of it I thought it
was the worst I thought it was a failure
I thought I was a loser I wasn't and by
the way the money on the back end
it's a totally different proposition
right so that pay cut that we took was
one of the greatest Investments we've
ever made as a family
but I want you to start an exercise I'm
going to send you a couple things I'm
going to send you a copy of my book on
your past change your future okay read
it with your wife
the second thing I'm going to send you
is
questions for humans the couple's
Edition I want you and your wife to
start spending some date time okay
so intimacy time it's not doesn't have
to be sex related that's just
communication we're talking again I'm
also going to send you my buddy Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
and I want you to read that thing start
to finish and start asking yourself some
of the bigger questions man I've got 10
years of management experience I'm
making great money I know how to work
hard
what kind of car do I want to be what
kind of engine do I put in this thing
over time is there something else I want
to do and you may Circle back and say
nope this is what I want to do I just
want to manage the time better I'm going
to start taking time off I'm going to
whatever
and take one of those older guys out to
lunch that you work with um one of the
dudes that's been there for 35 years and
he's 60.
take him back and say hey when you're 35
. give me some wisdom to your 35 year
old self
I did that once when I was working at a
print shop in college I was about two
years in and I was just bored of college
it was just boring and I worked at a I
was a delivery boy at a print shop and
there was these guys been working the
press for years the dude's name was
Merlin it's awesome guys incredible
drummer
and we went out to lunch one day just
it was awesome man his hands are ink
stained he's just a great human long
hair we went out and um I said what
would you would what would you tell me
your 20 year old self and he looked at
me and said graduate college
and he said it was a conviction of I
love my life I do well in my life
but there's more than this
and man working at print shops those
guys were incredible Vance Merlin those
dudes were awesome but he looked at me
in the eye and said graduate college
go beyond this and so sit down with
somebody's a little bit ahead of you and
ask for some wisdom there okay
you're on the right path my brother
Stephen and I'm grateful that you called
and thanks for letting me unpack all
that with you I know that was a little
bit of a longer unpacking but if you're
listening to this and you experience
panic attacks you experience anxiety
ask yourself some of the questions I
just asked Stephen what's my intimacy
like who am I hanging out with let's get
a medical checkup
am I safe financially am I safe in a
toxic work environment what's my sex
life and I'm like what what is the world
I've created for myself that my body is
telling me we cannot make it here
anymore
fixing your body is less important than
creating a new environment for yourself
to live in
and yes go outside and lift weights too